هذا واعلنت قوات الدعم السريع تسليم
الصليب الاحمر الدولي 27 عسكريا مصريا
كانوا موجودين في قاعده مروي العسكريه
وقالت دعم السريع انه تحفظ على الجنود
المصريين لمده خمسه ايام من الخامسه عشر
وحتى العشرين من الشهر الجاري واعلن
المتحدث العسكري المصري وصول الجنود الى
مقر السفاره المصريه في الخرطوم تمهيدا
لاجراءات اجلائهم من الاراضي السودانيه
فور استقرار الاوضاع
وقال بيان صادرون عن القياده العامه
للقوات السودانيه المسلحه انه بتنسيق بين
الجانبين السوداني والمصري تم امس اجلاء
177 فردا من الاطقم الفنيه للقوات الجويه
المصريه الى مصر من مطار دونكولا على متن
اربع طائرات مصريه واشار الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني الى ان الجنود المصريين
الذين تم اجلائهم ليسوا من المجموعه التي
تتالف من 28 جنديا اسرتهم قوات الدعم
السريع واضاف ان من سماها الميليشيا
المتمرده تتحمل المسؤوليه الكامله وتبعات
اسر واحتجاز جنود المصريين